So earlier this year in February I
reached the 100k subscriber mark,
thank you so much for that btw. I was planning
to do a 100k QnA video in February to celebrate
but ehhh I got busy, so we’re doing
it now, better late than never right?
I did a 10k subscriber QnA a while back
but if you didn’t watch that video,
I don’t blame you it’s kind of boring, I
am going to quickly address some of the
questions from that video that also came
up when I asked for questions this time.
So I was born in 97, I from Bratislava Slovakia,
I speak and read these languages, although
since the last video, I did pick up Latin
and I am intensively studying German as I need
to know both of those languages for my academics.
Anyways First Question.
Vodka or Rakija?
Pivo!
UNIVERSITY?
Currently, the University of Oxford
What events do you think were the biggest game
changers for Eastern Europe throughout history?
I have to say the migration period during the
early middle ages, although, I am quite biased
in this, you’ll find out why later. So basically
it was from the migration period that the current
cultural an ethnic makeup of not just Eastern
Europe but Europe in general stems from,
and it is this ethnic makeup that fueled much of
the nation-centric history of modern Europe and
still affects our politics to this day. Well,
there are actually a lot of caveats to that
statement I just said, and if you want to know
about them than read The Myth of Nations book,
but even then I don’t think any historians would
argue that the migration period wasn’t at least
ONE of the most influential
events in European history.
What is your favourite area
of history to look into?
What's your favourite time
period of history and why?
Well when you study history, once you’re past
your BA you have to specialize (sometimes even
during your BA) and I chose to specialize
in the area of history I liked the most,
which is the early medieval period. Even more
specifically I am an early eastern European
medievalist. That covers basically anything
dealing with the area east of the Franks
from the circa 6th century to the circa 10th
century. For example my Masters dissertation
focused on the Avaro-Slavic relations and their
evolution during the Khaganate’s existence.
I chose this particular area of history to focus
on because it basically deals with the migration
period and its aftermath, and as I have already
mentioned the migration period really was one of
the most influential events in European history
and the way it played out affected events all
the way to the 19th and 20th century, so it is
really important and also really interesting.
I chose to focus on Eastern Europe specifically
because that’s where I am from but also because
good current eastern European historians
that write about this time period that
aren’t affected by nationlistic or other agendas
are hard to come by. They definitely do exist,
it’s just that there's not that many of them,
and the couple of good ones that do exist
also don’t always publish in English
making their material even more obscure.
Would you consider doing any
alternate history videos?
No. Alternate history is fiction or
in other words historical fiction,
and I am not a fiction writer, I am a historian.
How did you get interested into history?
What started your love for history?
I cannot really say how it started. I just know I
was always interested in anything history related.
I loved going to the history museum in Bratislava
and the ones in Vienna and when I was a kid
everytime my family would travel somewhere we
would stop to see old castles and skanzens,
I even remember I had this passport like
collection book where every time you visited
a different castle in Slovakia and Czechia
you got a unique stamp of that castle in
the book and could than collect them. I also
remember that back then I was far more into
Roman history than I am now. I visited all the
Roman sites around Bratislava, like Carnuntum,
or the Roman military camp in Rusovce but now
that I am older when it comes to the classical
period I am actually far more interested in
Classical Greece than Rome. Although, of course,
the period I find the most interesting now is
the early medieval period as already mentioned.
So circling back, my answer is I have always been
interested in history and I cannot
really pinpoint when and how it started.
Explain historical relativism. Why
should/shouldn’t we apply it when evaluating
historical figures? In your opinion, what are
some pros and cons to historical relativism?
Uffff. Philosophy wasn’t my strongest
subject, but I can give my two cents.
So first, an extremely oversimplified explanation.
Relativism, is an idea that “right” and
“wrong”, or what is considered “truth”,
or just standards of reasoning, are relative,
meaning they differ from person to person, from
time period to time period and from culture to
culture. This means that the abstract properties
of things such as being morally right, or wrong,
or something looking beautiful are relative to
a given framework of assessment like cultural
norms, personal standards, etc. Due to this,
the meaning of statements like something
being morally right or wrong can only be
understood once the framework of assessment of an
individual or a group that made those statements,
is defined. In essence you cannot fully understand
an abstract statement by someone, for example
“this looks beautiful”, if you do not understand
their framework of assessment by which they
assessed that thing to be beautiful. However, you
yourself are also bound by a certain framework of
assessment by which you assess things like right
or wrong or something being beautiful. That
framework of assessment could be a combination
of your religious beliefs, cultural upbringing,
personal standards, etc. And since everyone
has this unique framework of assessment,
relativists argue that there exists no
independent vantage point from which to assess
whether something is truly morally “right”, or
“wrong”, or “beautiful” etc. It is all relative.
Due to this, in its most extreme form,
relativism can be used to condemn those
who project their own assessment of things
like morality towards acts like genocide,
which were conducted by peoples whose frameworks
of assessment completely differed from that of our
own and therefore, their assessment of what
is morally right or wrong differed as well.
Basically, who’s to say something
is morally right or wrong, when such
an abstract concept is defined by a person's
unique framework of assessment which by nature
has no independent vantage point. After all,
one man's hero is another man's villain.
Now relativism, just like any
other kind of philosophical ism,
has variations and different interpretations
and some of its parts overlap with other isms
like subjectivism and contextualism, but all this
is beyond the scope of answering this question.
However, I can give my opinion about
relativism being applied to history.
Humans have always had some kind of a
framework of assessment through which
they assessed abstract things like morality
or beauty or even love, and they have almost
always projected their assessments of
these things onto the past and sometimes
even the future. The framework of assessment
through which people assessed things
obviously changed over time and differed
between cultures and individuals.
The two main frameworks of assessment the
historian needs to take into considerations
when writing history are the ones of the people
in the time and area he’s writing about and in
the time and area he is from. Also important to
the context are the frameworks of assessment of
the people living in between then and now; this is
the historiography part of the historical essay.
What is usually the most contested
issue of all this is that people today,
including some historians, try to project
their current assessments of abstract ideas
like what is morally right or wrong, which are
defined by current frameworks of assessments,
onto the people in the past, even though,
the people in the past clearly had completely
different frameworks of assessment by which
they assessed what is morally right and wrong.
Relativists would argue that this projection
is a bad practice because as we have discussed
all abstract ideas like morality cannot be judged
because there doesn’t exist an independent vantage
point from which to judge them. However, I
would argue that doesn’t matter. People have
always had different frameworks of assessments
and they have always projected their assessment
of abstract ideas onto the past, why should we be
any different? I am sure there will be people 500
years from now talking about how our assessments
of morality and beauty were completely wrong.
We as a society, through our current
frameworks of assessment, have decided
that genocide is morally bad, and as such we
should treat genocide in history as morally bad.
With that said, what must be emphasized here, is
that the frameworks of assessment used by a person
or a peoples in assessing abstract ideas like
morality should be contextualised by a historian
because only then can a more fuller picture of
a historical event be gotten. It is important
to understand why a peoples in the past thought it
was morally justifiable to conduct a genocide, or,
on a lighter note, why they thought
a certain thing looked beautiful.
There are plenty of events or people
in the past that we would today
unequivocally call “bad” that at the time
might have been completely “normal” or even
milder than the norm, and I see no reason why
all this cannot be mentioned by a historian.
Stating that by our standards this person
was “terrible” due to these things but by the
standards of the time he wasn’t that bad because
of these frameworks of assessment of that time.
Hopefully that answers the
question. I am not really sure,
I myself got lost about half way
through explaining it. Anyways.
Lost historical works you'd love
the most to get your hands on?
I'd love to read the memoirs of
Sulla, such an interesting guy!
I know right away what work I want to get my
hands on. I would LOVE to get my hands on the
12th volume book on the history of the Goths by
Cassiodorus. You have no idea how much I thought
about this. We have only one book on the history
of the Goths and that is the Getica written by
Jordanes and that book has so many problems
and, is anyways, just a very poorly abridged
version of Cassiodorus’ work. Just imagine how
much more we would know, if we had that book,
not just about the Goths but also about the
history of early Eastern Europe. Like Cassiodorus,
in the book, most certainly talked about all
the other people that interacted with the Goths,
like the Slavs, the Huns, the Dacians, maybe
even Baltic tribes when the Goths were in the
north of Eastern Europe. Who knows just
how much new information we would gather
about the state of eastern Europe in the
late Classical and early medieval period.
Cassiodorus during his life founded a monastery
at Vivarium in southern Italy and I have thought
about how great it would be if in the ruins of
that monastery somewhere, a box or just parchment
containing the book would be found. It would be
so great. Alas, sadly that’s not gonna happen.
Is hot dog a sandwich?
No!
OMG would you defeat a horse size duck?
Well a functioning horse sized duck
clearly doesn’t follow the Square-cube law,
which means it’s a magical duck, and I
clearly cannot defeat a magical duck.
What is your favorite song?
Ahhh like how am I supposed
to answer that? Whatever I say I will
be judged by it forever even though
in reality I listen to a variety of music
genres ... You know what, what ever,
I don’t care, I am just going to look up
what's the most played song on my spotify …
And it is Starlight by Taylor
Swift, hehhehehe, judge away.
What books would you recommend about
History? (It can be any period/topic)
The one that comes to mind first, most likely
because I recently read it for my nomad video, is
The Cambridge History of Early Inner Asia it’s, I
think, the best introduction to the Eurasian Nomad
history there is, even though research wise it has
some outdated points, but it’s still really good.
For historical books I would always recommend
reading Thucydides, because even though he’s
very dry when compared to his contemporary
Herodotus, he is so analytical that I think
it's with him that the writing of History truly
started not with Herodotus. Don’t get me wrong,
Herodotus was still a good step forward, but he
did play lip service to supernatural events and
wrote in a more sensationalized story-like way
which was similar to how history was written
before the historical method. Basically
I view Herodotus as the transition from
fictionalized story telling of history like
the Iliad to using the historical method for
writing history which is what Thucydides did.
So to me Thucydides was the first historian
and therefore I think it’s important to read his
work. Plus you’ll notice that some of the things
he talks about are still applicable to this
day even though it was almost 2500 years ago.
Why'd you start, and what helps you keep going?
For this question I had like a two page answer
ready but in reality when I looked through it
I realized it was all really boring stuff, so
I am just going to extremely oversimplify it.
I started because 1. I wanted to be a YouTuber,
I know that sounds shallow but that was one of
the reasons nonetheless. 2. Because I just like
history and I have always read history books
so making videos about something I like just
sounded like fun. 3. History documentaries on TV
were getting worse and at that time there weren’t
that many history YouTubers on the platform so
I thought I was filling in a nice niche. 4. I
wanted to prove a concept to myself which was
that history is not a useless major to study and
I can actually make money with it if I don’t go
the traditional academic route, which in the end
I actually did go the traditional academic route,
but I don’t think I would have gone that route
if I didn’t have YouTube as kind of fall back.
Over time a 5th reason emerged for why
I do YouTube and that is “variety”.
Often as an academic historian you get
stuck in researching a single topic
in a single time period and sometimes this can
get a bit dull since there is little variety,
but with YouTube I can pick whatever topic I want
to research about and that is amazing. The variety
of topics I research into for YouTube really
does help me keep my passion for history as I
am not stuck with doing just one specific thing.
Everytime I feel a bit bored with my academic
work, I can go and research into the Viennese
Coffee House, or the Mexican War of Independence,
things that I would normally never write about if
I was just doing the traditional medievalist rout.
So I guess that explains why I started YouTube and
also why I am continuing doing it. Well, that and
the little extra money I get from it is also
nice, but don’t be fooled, it’s nothing major,
if it was I would be doing YouTube full time,
as it is, I am not, but maybe in the future.
What are the books you have used frequently
in your videos as reference and/or research?
What are some positives and negatives you
would personally say about each of them?
Since my video topics are all over the
place I rarely use the same book twice.
Like the books I used for the Maximilian video
are kind of useless for my Early Medieval Nomads
video. With that said, during my research
as an early eastern european medievalist
there is a book that comes up time and time again
and that is Curta’s The Making of the Slavs,
and a lot of people have a lot of
strong opinions about this book.
If you never read it, and you’re
interested in early Slavic history,
I definitely recommend reading it, even if
you already know the book's conclusion ahead
of time and you don’t agree with it, it is still
a remarkable piece of research you should read.
The amount of work Curta did to write it
is nothing less than astounding and it
contains the most complete information
on early Slavic sources out there.
With all that said though, Curta did use
postmodernist and Toronto School ideas for his
conclusion which many historians, including me,
don’t agree with. He views the Slavic ethnicity
as being socially constructed by outside observers
who imparted the Slavic ethnos upon a people who
did not have an ethnic identity. He expanded on
this point in his follow-up book published very
recently where he argued that the Slavic languages
were constructed as a lingua franca by various
peoples and they did not originate from a single
proto-Slavic language, which would support the
fact that the Slavic ethnicity did not originate
from a single ethnic identity but was rather
imparted on the quote “Slavic” people. Now I am
not going to get into why I don’t agree with Curta
because that would take far too long but in short
it seem to me that Curta’s ideas are an extreme
counterreaction to the prominent nationalistic and
conservative views of the many Eastern European
historians which honestly still last in one
way or another to this day in eastern Europe.
But yeah The Making of the Slavs is a very
prominent book and even though I don’t agree with
its conclusion, I have to say it is a must read
if you are interested in early Slavic history.
What is one area of history that
you would like to learn more about?
Area of history that I know almost nothing about
and would like to know more about
is classical and medieval China.
Area of history that I know a fair bit
about but also am aware that there’s still a
giant amount of history I don’t
know and would like to know
is, 19th and early 20th century
Europe, and Latin American history.
Has your general view of history
or worldview changed since
you've started doing history youtube?
If so, are there any videos you found
especially influential, or did these changes
come about gradually and in the background?
I mean definitely yes to the first part, although,
I would call it more evolved than changed but how
much YouTube has to do with all that is hard to
say. Since I started YouTube I lived in three
different countries, completed a BA a graduate
degree and a Masters degree, and met people
from all walks of life. All this obviously
affected my worldview more than YouTube did.
With that said, YouTube definitely helped me gain
numerous skills and the large amounts of research
I have done into a wide variety of topics due
to YouTube definitely affected the way I look
at history and the world around me but as I
said I don’t think it was the most influential
part of why my worldview evolved from where it
was 6 years ago. I also don’t think there was
any specific video I can really pinpoint
to as being the most influential in this.
Which time period are you
hoping to make more videos on?
Well unsurprisingly the early medieval
period. For example, I have been promising
a video on the early history of the
Romanians for a very long time now,
it’s just the topic is so convoluted
I am trying to figure out a way to
present it the most objectively I
can, and that is taking a long time.
But yeah, expect more early medieval history
videos. Although, I will never stop making
videos on random niche history things that
I get interested in for whatever reason.
Favourite type of cheese?
Well with me being a Slovak,
who actually loves bryndzove halusky, I
just HAVE to say my favorite type of cheese is
brindza. My hands are tied on this one, sorry.
What YouTube channels do you watch the most?
Well let's get the easy ones out of the way first.
Jesse Cox, Linus Tech Tips, Techlinked,
PolyMatter, Nativelang, Veritasium,
RTGame, and Captain Disillusion
are the ones I have watched the most
lately that aren’t history YouTubers.
When it comes to history YouTubers,
there are many that I am subscribed to,
I think like almost over 60 or something, but
there’s just not enough time in the world to
watch everything they release and in that sense
there are only a couple of history YouTubers whose
new videos I always watch. These are Jack
Rackam, Cogito, Guthlac, Historia Civilis,
History Marche, Cynical Historian, and
UsefulCharts. Of course, there are plenty
of other good history channels that I did not
mention and I would recommend checking out,
but I just personally don’t regularly watch those
channels as I don’t have unlimited amount of time.
What was your most challenging video to make?
Every video has its own unique challenges.
For example, the only source for the war of
the bucket video was in Italian so I had to
get someone to help me translate parts of it.
The only sources for the Drowning in poop video
were in Latin and German which, yes I am learning
those languages, but it was still a challenge
translating stuff, especially old manuscripts.
With that said, I will divide
this question into two questions,
Most frustrating video to make,
and most work done for a video.
I can tell you right away that the most
frustrating video to make was the Good
King Wenceslas Carol video. Specially because
at the time I was not as familiar with using
library databases as I am now, and also because
once I found out the truth about the carol
I realized to get to it I went the most
convoluted way possible, when in reality
I could have just looked up in some old reference
book all the works done by Václav Alois Svoboda,
and there see that he did write the story
of Good King Wenceslas but to be fare that
wouldn’t make as much of an entertaining
story as it did so maybe it’s for the best.
The most work I have done for a video, is either
the Slavic Vennetic connection or the Treaty of
Saint Germain and the breakup of Austria,
it depends on how you define “work”. The
Slavic Vennetic connection is something that is
part of my expertise and therefore even though
over all that video definitely needed the most
research, I have already done that research during
my academics so when it came to actually doing
the video I did not have to do that much work.
The Breakup of Austria video was on
the opposite side of that spectrum,
where I had to basically start my research
from scratch. Well that’s not completely true,
I mean I do know probably more than the average
person about Austria Hungary mainly because I
like reading about its history, but the topic
is far from my expertise and therefore I
always approach the research with the mentality
as if I don’t know anything about it. So even
though there was less research overall compared to
the Slavic Venetic connection video, I had to do
all the research from scratch. Plus I made an
entire freaking language map of 1910 Austria,
so come to think of it, yeah, probably the
most work I did for a video was for that one.
I only talked about research here not
editing, mainly because I find editing to be
very monotonous and similar from video to video
and therefore the amount of editing work required
for a video is always correlated with its length
rather than anything else. Plus my time and
effort spent editing is usually much smaller
than my time spent writing and researching.
What type of videos would you like to make but
can’t because of lack of
views/YouTube disliking it?
To my detriment I don’t think there is
a video I wouldn’t make due to a lack
of views or YouTube disliking it. It is a
terrible business decision but if I want
to make a YouTube video about a certain
topic I’ll make a video about that topic.
I mean I never thought the Avar siege
of Byzantium video or the Medieval
Nomads video would do well. I just
wanted to make those videos so I did.
Although this sentiment comes from the fact that I
don’t do YouTube full time and I do still focus on
my academics, so I can afford making videos about
topics I know won't do that well. However, in the
future, when I start doing YouTube full time, this
sentiment would most likely change. Which sucks,
but that is the nature of the
platform. I’ll probably just
start doing videos like History Matters does.
If you’re not a big fan of that then the only
way to change that really is if I had way more
Patreons than I have now, because that’s the
only way for me to not be as financially
reliant on the algorithm and the views.